la boîte noire du dc-10 du thé à
retrouver dans le désert l'explosion à
bord et donc sans doute
l'attentât est la thèse la plus
plausible gorbatchev fait le ménage il
élimine deux de ses principaux opposants
des conservateurs pour poursuivre sa
politique de réponse le président du cnf
peu un parti d'extrême droite
maintenu en détention qui sont ces
étranges militants extrémistes reportage
drames de l'enfance martyrs en charente
un adolescent enfermé depuis six ans
dans une cave par son beau père bonsoir
le mystère du dc-10 du désert depuis
hier soir nous n'avons pas eu beaucoup
d'informations supplémentaires sur ce
drame
il faut dire que l'avion du téat s'est
écrasé au milieu d'un désert qui est
grand comme la france
seule certitude il n'y a pas de
survivant en revanche on l'a appris il
ya quelques minutes la boîte noire de
l'appareil vient d'être retrouvé quant
aux causes de la catastrophe est bien la
thèse d'un attentat qui aurait fait
exploser l'avion en plein vol et la plus
plausible
les débris du dc-10 sont est parti et
éparpillé pardon en effet sur des
kilomètres et des kilomètres carrés
alors voici les premières images prises
d'avion par nos envoyés spéciaux
dominique verdeilhan une empreinte
noirâtre dans un océan de sable l'impact
principal du dc-10 une carlingue
disloqué au milieu de ce cratère seuls
quelques morceaux de métal calciné sont
facilement reconnaissables
plus loin d'autres morceaux de l'épave
plus important la dérive de l'appareil à
côté peut-être un réacteur à plus de 6
kilomètres de ce point d'impact
les premiers secours arrivés hier
après-midi ont repéré une partie du
fuselage
plus loin le cockpit et par pied sur une
superficie de plus de 50 kilomètres
carrés jonchant les dunes du désert du
ténéré des débris métalliques mais aussi
les effets personnels
de nombreux passagers étaient toujours à
six anglais sur leur siège
un dernier passage à l'an à votre gauche
vous allez avoir dans un premier temps
les hélicoptères
à droite peu
à gauche également là
principale et à droite des brodé brisé
deux hélicoptères puma ont été les
premiers à arriver sur les lieux 24
heures après la catastrophe pour les
sauveteurs très vite
une certitude il n'y a aucun survivant
parmi les 171 occupants de l'appareil
pour les enquêteurs la disposition des
débris laisse à penser que l'appareil a
explosé en plein vol ce soir les boîtes
noires ont été retrouvées
elles permettront peut-être avec l'étude
des débris de connaître les
circonstances exactes du drame
retrouver des pièces d'abord de
l'appareil qui ont été déformés il est
évident que si on trouve des pièces
étrangères
c'est une bonne présentation par contre
ils payeront aussi les déformations cas
d'explosion des caisses se déforme et ne
se déforme pas nécessairement de la même
façon que si c'était une rupture une
déchirure de l'appareil comme cause
initiale il y a donc un travail je
dirais presque de reconstitution de deux
parties de l'avion en fin d'après midi
les premiers corps des passagers du vol
ut 772 ont été transférés vers n'djamena
le pis ce matin des mesures
particulières de sécurité ont été prises
dans les aéroports pour tous les avions
du téat il s'agit d'une fouille plus
approfondie des bagages
et puis bien sûr de l'obligation pour
les passagers de reconnaître leurs
bagages
juste avant de monter dans l'avion le
pdg du thé à rooney a pour autres a dit
tout a dit sur tout à l'heure son
impuissance à faire face au terrorisme
il faut dit-il qu'en amont les
gouvernements luttent contre ce fléau et
monsieur l'apôtre refuse d'être tenu
pour responsable de toute la chaîne de
sécurité écouter s'il faut fouiller tous
les bagages de tous les passagers il
faut se mettre dans une situation qui
est simple qui est celle de pays en
guerre
ça prend des délais considérables avec
une efficacité d'ailleurs pantale total
si déjà la sécurité n'est pas
complètement assurée dans des aéroports
comme francfort où l'ombre ou l'a vu
récemment à fortiori
dans beaucoup d'ailleurs encore geoffrey
qu est ce que vous avez reçu récemment
des menaces n'ont absolument aucune
je crois qu terrain n'est pas en cause
dans cette affaire certains jours
présenter les informations c'est annoncé
toute une série de catastrophes et
accumuler les bilans macabres c'est
hélas le cas aujourd'hui
au chapitre transport aérien il y a par
exemple l'accident ce boeing 737 à new
york
le pilote a tenté d'interrompre le
décollage de son appareil au dernier
moment il n'a pas réussi à contrôler son
avion et le boeing a terminé sa course
en bout de piste dans liszt river il ya
au moins deux morts et 41 blessés
au chapitre au chapitre transporterait
la collision aux états unis au texas
entre un car de ramassage scolaire et un
camion il ya 15 morts
au maroc c'est un train qui a percuté un
car de touristes français là aussi le
bilan est lourd il y a six morts et sept
blessés graves
et puis autre catastrophe bien sûr c'est
à l'échelle d'une région entière cette
fois ce sont les ravages causés par le
cyclone hugo aux antilles l'ouragan
poursuit sa route et atteindrait demain
après midi les côtes de caroline du sud
aux états unis
en guadeloupe on en est encore à mesurer
l'ampleur des dégâts ils sont immenses
il n'y a pas que l'habitat qui étaient
détruits il ya aussi les cultures comme
celle des bananes par exemple agnès
poirier dominique merlin reportage
j'aurais eu vers vannes mais redémarre à
zéro ses dix hectares de bananier on se
fait broyer par le cyclone il va lui
falloir un mois pour couper nettoyer
nourrir la terre épuisé faire repartir
la plante jeu et huberman ne veut pas
avouer son découragement
pourtant il fait qu'il n'aura pas de
récolte avant neuf mois le hangar où il
emballé les bananes et détruit il s'est
déjà endettés pour investir il va devoir
mettre ces trois ouvriers en chômage
technique
sa seule ressource aujourd'hui c'est que
l'état français lui vienne en aide
tout de suite après le tourisme ce sont
les bananeraies qui font vivre la
guadeloupe au siège du syndicat des
producteurs de bananes on demande des
mesures immédiates pour ces planteurs
créole on les appelle les békés qui
possèdent les plus grosses exploitations
de l'île et composent le conseil
d'administration du syndicat
la profession est sinistrée à 100% si
nous n'avons pas une une aide
conséquente vous permettre
l'implantation la remise en état des
cultures y voit pas de redémarrage de
banana boat l'état français n'oubliera
pas les producteurs guadeloupéens
le ministre des dom-tom l'assuré comme
joaillier verveine mais la plupart
d'entre eux n'ont que quelques hectares
et travaille en famille ils attendent
maintenant du syndicat qu'il
répartissent l'aide de la france le plus
équitablement possible
et puisqu'il faut continuer notre triste
litanie ceci encore un hélicoptère qui
participaient aux secours aux sinistrés
en guadeloupe s'est abîmé en mer
c'est cet hélicoptère a esté sauveteurs
que nos envoyés spéciaux avaient filmé
hier il s'est écrasé au large de l'île
de la désirade
il y a au total cinq morts et trois
disparus
enfin il faut parler de cette tragique
prise d'otages dans la banlieue de liège
en belgique
elle dure depuis samedi dernier mais il
ya du nouveau peut-être depuis quelques
minutes les gangsters pourrait libérer
les deux jeunes enfants alors tout de
suite nous allons retrouver notre envoyé
spécial bruno gex n'ai écouté d'abord ce
que disait il ya quelques minutes le
procureur
la proposition formulée par les
autorités judiciaires ont été acceptées
par les ravisseurs
c'est trop conditions sont les suivantes
il change les deux enfants contre la
remise en deux fois une somme totale de
30 millions de francs benz 2 après les
changes limon sortie des ravisseurs dans
un véhicule leur fournit les autorités
judiciaires entendent respecter la
parole donnée sur le cours des
négociations
elle demande que les frères de ce
communiqué ne soit diffusée l'accusent
rapidement vos souvent barricadés dans
la villa des joris philippe delaire et
ses deux complices ont donc fini par
entendre le message des autorités belges
si les deux fillettes gaël et françoise
sont libérés il reste la maire marie
madeleine joris aux mains des ravisseurs
c'est peut-être elle qui a été à
l'origine de ce rebondissement à 16
heures
la situation est montée d'un cran at-il
philippe delaire a dans un premier temps
annoncé que la mère des fillettes
avaient eu un malaise
on a même parlé d'une tentative de
suicide 16h20 marie-madeleine joris
téléphone elle même aux policiers et
annonce que son état de santé s'est
amélioré
19 heures le procureur du roi et le
premier substitut viennent informer les
journalistes que les preneurs d'otages
au fini par accepter leurs propositions
la politique avec les ultras de
l'extrême droite l'attention a été
attirée sur récemment parce que le
président du pmf claude cornilleau s'y
retrouver en prison est aujourd'hui le
juge a décidé de son maintien en
détention
il serait impliqué dans l'attentât
raciste du foyer sonacotra de cagnes sur
mer
alors nous avons voulu savoir qui
étaient ces ultras extrémistes ces
militants d'un genre un peu particulier
et roland sicard jean cornu reportage
claude cornilleau le président du parti
nationaliste français et européen était
apparu pour la dernière fois en public
il y à un mois c'était le congrès
européen de l'ultra droite
un rendez vous qui se tient chaque année
et où les militants français belges
anglais allemands hollandais exposé
leurs idées sortent leur drapeau et
leurs uniformes
depuis claude cornilleau a été arrêté
dans le cadre de l' enquête sur
l'attentât du foyer de la sonacotra de
décembre 88 un mort et 12 blessés
une action pour laquelle plusieurs
membres du pn et feu avait déjà été mis
sous les verrous
jusqu'ici l'organisation avait gardé le
silence et le nid à présent tout en bloc
pense que c'est proprement scandaleux
laurent guyot a été arrêté non pas parce
qu'il lui reprochait officiellement ou
tout simplement pour un délit d'opinion
parce qu'il est nationaliste et parce
qu'il représente l'opposition la plus
radicale face au régime actuel sur le
fond vous le désapprouver cet attentat
sur le fond oui ce ne sont pas des
méthodes de lutte politique désaccords
affichés sur les méthodes mais pour le
reste le penne feu annonce la couleur
côté apparence chemise sombre et croix
celtiques côté idée un intérêt non
dissimulé pour le régime hitlérien un
nationalisme de combat et des tests sur
lesquels se retrouvent l'ultra-droite de
plusieurs pays européens
nous ne sommes pas partis démocratiques
dont jetons la démocratie et la société
multiraciale la démocratie parce qu'elle
produit les mêmes mots dans tous les
pays d'europe à savoir le chômage
l'invasion allogènes la baisse de la
natalité le sida la drogue
nous on veut préparer la troisième
guerre mondiale qui vaut ce ne sera pas
une guerre entre les idéologies
dénoncera une guerre entre les races on
voit tous les jours dans la rue
des propos qui jusqu'ici ne vais pas
inquiéter outre mesure les enquêteurs il
estime à 500 france le nombre de
militants du pn et feu le juge
d'instruction de grasse chargé du
dossier des attentats de la côte d'azur
lui poursuit son enquête
un policier membre d'un syndicat de
police d'extrême droite est recherché
dix personnes sont d'ores et déjà sous
les verrous
la rentrée du patronat françois périgot
le président du cnpf donner son point de
vue cet après midi sur l'automne social
et sur les grands choix économiques
alors essentiellement bien sûr le
conflit peugeot et le budget présenté
hier par le ministre de l'économie
véronique auger
habituez vous à cette image désormais le
patronat est dirigée par une troïka à
bouche du président l'homme de
l'économie patron d'une holding
industrielle et financière à droite
l'homme du social qui dirige une grosse
entreprise des travaux publics
ils savent qu'on les attend au tournant
sur le conflit peugeot ils savent qu'ils
marchent sur des oeufs
leur réponse sera laissée monsieur
qu'elle fait tranquille jusqu'ici il a
bien mené son affaire
d'ailleurs ajoute il s'est accompli
isolé mais ne nous laissons pas obnubilé
par un conflit social qui est grave
c'est vrai et puis un conflit social
c'est toujours extraordinairement
pénible pour ceux qui le vivent
et pour ceux qui le regardent mais enfin
un conflit social ne fait pas le climat
social de la france
autre point d'agacement du cnpf le
fameux pacte de croissance du premier
ministre il risque de créer de faux
espoirs pour les salariés du privé
on donne l'impression que la croissance
si finalement la constitution d'un
espèce de tas d'or d'un pactole qui est
là qui est parfaite partie dutil qui ne
doit série revient dans l'avenir alors
qu'il est là pour servir dans l'avenir
puisqu'il est là et bien il faut le
distribuer la façon dont on partage des
bénéfices de l'entreprise doit être
laissée absolument à la discrétion à
l'initiative de ceux qui ont la
responsabilité de la diriger enfin le
cnpf qui apparemment souhaite à tout
prix se démarquer du gouvernement le
cnpf trouve le futur budget
insatisfaisant il pénaliserait trop les
cadres le président mitterrand a lui
aussi parlé de l'actualité sociale tout
à l'heure des inspecteurs des impôts en
grève ont manifesté lors de sa visite à
l'hôpital henri mondor de créteil
le président inauguré un service pour
les personnes âgées et écouter ce qu'il
a dit sur les revendications
écoutez monsieur mitterrand ici elle a
acheté comme ailleurs certain nombre de
groupes sociaux socioprofessionnelles
qui en appelle à la puissance publique
qui veulent débattre discuter autour de
revendications dont l'inspiration est
légitime celle de vivre mieux avec des
voyait plus conséquent étant bien
entendu que tout cela n'aurait pas de
sens si l'ensemble de la maison side
nation dans son ensemble devait être
bousculée au point que finalement chacun
souffrirait de la perte une substance
qui signifierait une nouvelle gestion et
l'essentiel c'est de donner des ordres
sont dus à chacun chaque groupe social à
chaque individu et le ce point de vue
c'est très bon c'est très utile
d'entendre exprimé même fortement les
aspirations les besoins le grand coup de
balai de mikhaël gorbatchev à l'occasion
du plénum du comité central à moscou
c'était hier monsieur gorbatchev n'y est
pas allé de main morte il a remanié
carrément la direction de son parti il a
mis sur la touche deux des principaux
conservateurs du parti
peu à peu le numéro un soviétique tente
ainsi de s'imposer georges bortoli
monsieur gorbatchev frange de cette
soirée serait il venait d'éliminer 3g 12
membres du politburo l'un scratch es1 du
parti communiste sur ces trois exclus de
au moins étaient des personnalités
considérées comme réticente à son égard
l'ukrainien scherbatsky d'abord doyen du
politburo à 71 ans s'était montré assez
habile pour se trouvait en voyage aux
etats-unis en 1985 au moment même où
l'on était en train dé lire monsieur
corbacho ce qui lui avait permis à les
poches de ne brouille est fini avec les
pros ni avec les antilles gorbatchev
il a fini par fortis s'en va également
monsieur thierry costes ex grand patron
du kgb qui à plusieurs reprises a
critiqué publiquement la politique de
monsieur gorbatchev alors pour remplacer
ses partants le skate en général a fait
rentrer au politburo deux hommes qui
passent pour être de ses fidèles
il y a monsieur iouchkov actuel patron
du kgb et monsieur string of à qui il
avait déjà donné plusieurs promotions
brillante
autrement dit il semble bien que ce soir
monsieur gorbatchev et renforcer sa
majorité au bureau politique
alors merci georges est avec nous
maintenant en direct de moscou
monsieur vadim perf ylieff le porte
parole du ministère des affaires
étrangères soviétique alors bonsoir
monsieur père filière à la hanche fois
dites moi c'est une sacrée purge tout de
même que viennent servi qu'à
m.gorbatchev parce que il se débarrasse
des conservateurs il se débarrasse de
ses ennemis au fond bien ce qu'il ya de
commun de ces gens qui sont partis
maintenant du bureau politique se leur
âge je sois si la santé qui n'étaient
pas excellentes pour cela il ya aussi en
commun il ya des deux par exemple
monsieur soloviov qui a quitté son poste
à leningrad qui lui a valu ce justement
la place dans le bureau politique et il
ya monsieur à lézinnes qui auparavant a
aussi perdu sa place dans le
gouvernement donc il s'agit de départ
des gens qui sont allés à la retraite
qui ont été d'ailleurs remercié par le
plénum par monsieur gorbatchev lui-même
et je crois qu'on pourrait quand même
commencer à s'habituer à ce que le
bureau politique
le secrétariat du comité central du
parti communiste sera juni et d'ailleurs
c'est l'exemple il y à tous les
secrétaires du comité central qui sont
rentrés maintenant il faut bien voir
l'importance de ce mouvement
ils sont tous nés l'âge la fin en 1936
monsieur ousmanov aller
le plus ancien de nouveaux secrétaires
promu va pas les énumérer georges
bortoli veux vous poser une question
mais on n'en parle pas on parle de ce
qui entre justement alors les deux
principaux ceux qui veulent viennent
d'être nommés membres titulaires du
politburo là et responsable grand patron
du kgb l'autre a passé toute sa vie
comme spécialiste de l'industrie de
l'armement de l'industrie de guerre
alors est ce qu'avec de telles fonctions
on peut les considérer comme des grands
libéraux
vous savez il faudrait quand même
monsieur bortoli vous connaissait bien
les réalités soviétique et nous avons eu
à la tête de notre kgb comme vous dites
mais qu'un bébé alors plutôt des gens
assez important qui ont joué un très
grand rôle dans l'état n'oublions pas
nos sur un drop trouve par exemple
alors ces gens monsieur max lykov je
voudrais aussi dire son âge né en 1937
cet incident que quelqu'un que c'est
parce qu'on est jeune données libéral
non mais je voudrais dire que le bureau
politique ce qu'il y a comme conclusion
la plus commune pour tous ceux qui sont
rentrés dans le bureau politique et le
secrétariat c'est la jeunesse c'est le
dynamisme
ce sont les gens qui participent
directement et activement dans la pile
aistrika et si vous voulez en deux mots
le plénum c'était un peu le pied
l'estrie cas dans le pays et stricker
parce que le parti s'est occupé à faire
de sorte qu'elle puisse donner encore un
élan à tout ce mouvement et c'est pour
cela d'ailleurs monsieur bortoli qu'on a
décidé d'avancer dans les temps le
congrès du parti comique 28e congrès et
cette équipe
cette équipe rajeunie d'ailleurs avec un
secrétariat qui peut être reprendre
encore de l'importance pour préparer ce
congrès c'est secrétariat donc dynamique
et jeune qu'on va préparer quelque chose
de très très important dans cette 4e et
5e année de la paix l'estrie quelques
sera jeu congrès dites moi monsieur
faire fi lle fait ce que michael
gorbatchev va profiter de son pouvoir
nouveau un peu accru pour améliorer le
niveau de vie des soviétiques parce que
de ce côté là ça va pas très bien en ce
moment
oui ça ne va pas encore
très bien mais justement ce que nous
avons vu pendant plénum c'était une
direction qui s'est montré tout à fait
décidée à aller de l'avant dans un pays
africain
c'était loin de ses prévisions de voir
enfin une direction de boussole et une
direction cherche entre quelque chose
comme la médiane entre les différentes
possibles direction etc
mais c'est vraiment la continuation
d'une manière très résolus de ce
mouvement révolutionnaire de la
perestroïka et les gestionnaires et les
nationalités alors ce plénum il était
fait en principe pour résoudre le
problème des revendications des
nationalités
or j'ai l'impression que ce plénum a
surtout décidé de ne rien décider alors
est-ce que cet immobilisme apparent ne
veut pas provoquer une explosion
eh bien monsieur bortoli vous avez bien
vu bien sûr vu nous avons publié cela à
moirans la plateforme le projet de
plateforme sur les questions nationales
maintenant le plénum il va y la paix
devient de d'avoir quelques changements
dans le libellé de cette plateforme mais
c'est un document assez important vous
l'avez vu bien sûr oui mais c'est tout
un programme de la décision des
questions nationales
je crois que ce que nous avons vu la
dent enfin la vision du parti
c'était la décision de faire de sorte
que cette fédération des républiques
socialistes soviétiques puisse continuer
puisse continuer à trouver les
meilleures possibilités de vie de toutes
les populations qui nous habite
évidemment ce que nous voyons maintenant
ce tulle enfin cette amère merde
problème et ce n'est pas un ce n'est pas
quelque chose de tout à fait plat ce
n'est pas un patinoire donc il ya des
vagues
il ya des hauts et des bas mais il ya
aussi les et stylisme il y a aussi des
séparatismes et je crois monsieur woerth
alliés que ça ceci est vrai non pas
seulement pour un pays socialiste mais
pour pas mal de pays dans le monde
merci merci nous aurons l'occasion de
reparler de tout cela certainement c'est
un sujet important
merci beaucoup le reste de l'actualité
internationale avec ces exécutions
publiques en arabie
vous dites 16 chiffres faux et tient
presque tous d'origine iranienne ont été
décapités au sabre en place publique
il avait été reconnu coupable d'un
attentat en juillet dernier au cours du
pèlerinage de la mecque un dossier
embarrassant pour la nouvelle calédonie
et plus précisément pour les accords de
matignon il s'agit de révélations
publiées par notre confrère le monde le
monde publie en effet aujourd'hui deux
des extraits de deux rapports qui met en
cause le rpcr ce parti aurait profité de
passe droit dans l'attribution de terres
dans le territoire explications de
rachid arhab
les deux rapports dont fait état le
monde sont accablants pour les partisans
de jacques lafleur le leader anti
indépendantistes
certains de ses proches auraient
bénéficié d' extravagante faveur dans
l'attribution de terrains en tout genre
un domaine qui en nouvelle calédonie est
extrêmement sensible
d'après le rapport de l'inspection
générale des finances l'attribution de
sept heures auraient été faites quasi
systématiquement en faveur de caldoches
de la période 86 88 par la draft l'
agence de développement rural mis en
place par le gouvernement de jacques
chirac
la publication de ces documents par des
voies encore inconnue mais donc
également en cause la politique du
secrétaire d'état aux dom-tom de
l'époque bernard course
les deux rapports divulgués aujourd'hui
sont sur le bureau de michel rocard
depuis plusieurs mois déjà mais après
les accords de matignon et le retour de
la paix en nouvelle calédonie le
gouvernement a certainement estimé qu'il
n'était pas opportun de fragiliser l'un
des signataires de ces accords en
l'occurrence jacques lafleur et cela
d'autant plus que les indépendantistes
de leur côté étaient prêts à régler
toutes ces affaires à l'amiable
en politique on appelle cela la raison
d'état une raison d'état qui n'empêche
pas de se poser quelques questions qui a
intérêt à faire circuler ces documents
s'agit-il véritablement d'une tentative
de déstabilisation de la nouvelle
calédonie ou tout simplement d'arguments
de compte politique
d'autres informations de l'actualité de
ce jour international économique social
et on commence par le conflit peugeot on
a observé aujourd'hui une légère détente
anne pons idée
collecte de solidarité aujourd'hui à
mulhouse pour les grévistes de peugeot
au 15e jour de leur action à montbéliard
manifestation de grévistes venue de
sochaux et mulhouse
par ailleurs suite à une décision de
peugeot l'accès des usines est désormais
interdit aux journalistes
30 min fou réunis à matignon aujourd'hui
au tour de michel rocard pour rénover
l'administration du service public
seize mesures dont amélioration du
service à l'usager responsabilisation
des agents et valorisation de leur
travail
il y a une intelligence considérable des
agents qui n'est pas utilisé il faut la
requérir au service de l'état grenade
lacrymogène contre pierres pétards et
facto les affrontements éleveur de
moutons gendarmes ont fait 13 blessés
hier à confolens dans les charentes
un nouvel acteur dans la sphère boutboul
marcel rozier médaillé d'or aux jeux de
76 de source judiciaire
c'est à partir d'un compte bancaire lui
appartenant comme halak aux blues bull
aurait retiré de l'argent en suisse
marcel rose il reste ce soir très
discret rien à dire là-dessus bon je
suis pas un homme à me cacher j'ai fait
mon travail je travaille aujourd'hui
j'ai fait une journée comme tout le
monde
je suis comme tout le monde j'ai écouté
des choses à la radio qui m'ont un petit
peu retourné pour le dire mais c'est
comme ça et malheureusement les gens
sont mal informés
andreas papandreou ex premiers ministres
socialistes comparaîtra devant une cour
spéciale pour l' affaire des écoutes
téléphoniques décision hier soir du
parlement grec par soit 169 voix contre
2 et socialistes n'ont pas voté
début aujourd'hui de la dernière vague
du retrait vietnamienne du cambodge
officiellement 26 mille soldats
vietnamiens doit partir avant le 27
septembre prochain
l'armée de hanoi était temps que
cambodge il ya dix ans
et
à la bourse de paris en hausse de 0 15%
de l'indicateur de tendance cours
officiel du dollar si france 58 25 le
drame d'un enfant martyr maintenant cela
se passe en charente l'enfant s'appelle
un adolescent il s'appelle loïc il a 13
ans depuis six ans son beau père le
faisait dormir dans une cave sans
lumière et sans chauffage pour le punir
de ne pas être propre lit le beau-père
et écroués michel perron loïc rentre de
l'école
aujourd'hui il dormira probablement dans
une chambre comme ses frères et soeurs
depuis six ans il vivait dans cette cave
privée de lumière et de chauffage
son beau père l'avait relégué la soupe
rétais qu'à 13 ans il faisait encore
pipi au lit
loïc et ses deux frères et soeurs
étaient issus d'un premier mariage de
leur mère
d'abord simplement rejetés ils furent
peu à peu victimes de privations puis de
mauvais traitements des coups pieds des
coupons bon toutou et parfois ils
avaient des bleus il avait des marques
louis et loïc lui ne disait rien les
voisins non plus d'ailleurs qui pourtant
que ce doute est quelque chose quand on
est les cris j'entendais aussi souvent
le moment après loïc d'un petit loïc moi
j'ai eu qui le frappait même méchamment
projet il était pas faire du fichier
finalement certains d'entre eux se sont
décidées à parler
lundi les gendarmes ont arrêté le
beau-père de l'enfant il a été inculpé
de coups et blessures volontaires et
écrouée la danse maintenant pour
terminer ce qui donnera à la fin de ce
journal une tonalité nettement plus gai
le new york city ballet est à paris au
théâtre des champs-elysées c'est la
fameuse troupe que baryshnikov a rendu
célèbre jean-claude d'arrigo et
jean-marie lequertier sont allés
observer les entrechats les pattes deux
classiques parfois contemporain souvent
la danse
ils sont originaires du nouveau monde et
pourtant leurs valets est un
conservatoire des solides traditions de
la chorégraphie
ce sont tous les disciples de val en
chine ce sont les enfants de balanchine
et balanchine et n est pas le plus
grands chorégraphes de notre siècle
après on est les petits pas donc
vraiment c'est ça qui fait de la troupe
c'est à voir rien m comme valence qui
dit balanchine dit l'a66 nommé
classicisme ne signifie pas
nécessairement fixation dans une
expression entremise ans ont passé
sous l'impulsion de peter martins la
troupe danse aussi bien gisèle que les
chorégraphies de jérôme robbins ou des
grands créateurs contemporains
mais personne ne sera étonné que le new
york city ballet tu sois
particulièrement à l'aise dans le style
américain qui n'est pas sans nous
rappeler comme ici quelques ballets de
comédies musicales célèbres
new york city ballet un style en tout
cas probablement la meilleure formation
chorégraphique des états unis voilà ça
au moins ça donne une grande bouffée
d'optimisme alors il y avait aussi
aujourd'hui un tiers t on va voir les
résultats tiercé 11 13 4 je vous laisse
lire les rapports sur l'écran et puis il
y avait un kart et simple alors 11 13 4
et 15 et je vous laisse encore lire les
rapports sur votre écran tout de suite
la météo avec laurent cabrol après un
peu de pub et avant un peu d'autres pubs
à 22h30 23h par là c'est henri sannier
pour la dernière édition du journal
demain c'est lé matin 6h30 avec mady
tran tu m'as dit ram et gérard morin
pour les journaux bonsoir à demain 20
heures
à